now I'm writing this before the Emmys
and if I had to guess they probably gave
the best drama series to succession
because rightfully so it's an incredible
show but unfortunately if that is the
case then that means Better Call Saul
has not won best drama series a single
time and because of how upsetting that
statement is I wanted to make this video
and analyze why Better Call Saul is the
best show of
2023 so the first and most important
reason to me is that better call saw
features and absolutely engrossing on
some double cast of characters they're
all extremely deep and have intricate
Dynamics it's honestly really hard to
pick a favorite but if I was held at
gunpoint then I'd probably pick Kim
Wexler everyone in the show I think is
outstanding but Kim essentially excels
past them and special to me because
there's a lot of poor examples of female
characters in media Kim as a character I
think is a perfect example as to how to
write a strong independent and fierce
woman the writers uke him with a great
amount of ferocious energy energy when
it comes to handling conflict that it
makes her captivating to watch every
time she explodes and eviscerates a
character with only her words it's so
mesmerizing because of how smart she is
and this aspect about Kim doesn't make
her a mean character or anything because
she has one of the strongest moral
consciousnesses in the show her desire
in wanting to make a difference in the
world and help the underdog is a wholly
endearing character trait she's like a
perfect storm of characteristics that if
written competently makes an excellent
character which Vince Gilligan and the
other writers for Better Call Saul do so
expertly there's not a single moment in
which I thought Kim Wexler was written
poorly or a single line of dialogue was
wasted and that's kind of the case for
everyone in the show because of how
Immaculate and detailed the writing is
overall another aspect that elevates Kim
and makes her even more fun to watch are
the characters surrounding her the
general space for law practices in these
big corporations are predominantly male
dominated in seeing a female character
break through and trample the these
characters with nothing more than her
wit and drive is extremely captivating
and inspiring the scene in which Kevin
from Mesa Verde is disappointed in Kim
and contemplates firing her and she
actually reverses the entire Dynamic by
turning the blame on Kevin was pure
excellence and Kevin I have to tell you
whoever represents you in the future I
hope you're going to listen to them a
little bit better the show of high
confidence and willingness to not back
down against people in charge and
impressed Kevin so much that he wanted
to keep working with her even the scene
where she successfully convinces Lo that
Jimmy wasn't lying about the whole money
ordeal was amazing Jimmy in that scene
was floundering and she actually saves
Jimmy and is the one to outp persuade Lo
her pure wits intelligence and Brass
nature is infectious and those
characteristics combined with her gender
makes her a massive role model like I
can honestly just watch a Kim Wexler
spin-off show where she demolishes
people in court every episode she's
essentially the people's champion and
another thing that is pretty refreshing
is the writers don't wave around the
fact that she's a female they're solely
focused on creating a compelling
character because at the end of the day
whether you're a guy or a girl you have
your own set of strengths and flaws and
one of my favorite moments for Kim as a
character was a scene towards the end of
the show where all of her emotions
essentially boil over and she breaks
down in public throughout the show she's
had a strong exterior and rarely showed
a lot of vulnerability emotionally
however In This Moment since she's
essentially drudging up the horrific
past of Howard's demise and she isn't
bearing it alongside Jimmy and acting
like it didn't happen she can't help but
break down and cry it's a deeply
personal and moving moment because it's
such a convention break for the
character and if anything makes her even
more relatable and human now let's go
into the relationship of Jimmy and Kim
because I honestly think this is one of
the best relationship dynamics that I've
ever seen I can't really think think of
a lot that can compete because there's
such an intriguing counterbalance
Dynamic to Jimmy and Kim's relationship
it funnily enough is like the scales of
Justice icon in which when Kim and Jimmy
are together they're at an equilibrium
point for each other now this obviously
isn't a good equilibrium but it
essentially enables Kim's worst impulses
while also tempering Jimmy's and keeping
him in check Jimmy when in the presence
of Kim wants to be the best version of
himself so that she'll love him more
seeing him grapple with the conundrum of
whether or not he should tell her the
truth about what happened in the desert
was heart-wrenching because this moment
could lead to their breakup but it in
fact actually strengthened their
relationship because Jimmy told the
truth and his core character wasn't
tarnished by it then for Kim she has a
deep-seated exposure to criminal
Behavior through her mother the show is
kind of vague as to how much this
impacted her but it makes sense to get a
rush from doing things that are slightly
out of the law as long as they aren't
too far so when around Jimmy she can't
help herself because it's eoric for her
to execute schemes with Jimmy that
always pay off magnificently when
together they balanced each other out to
an exact morality and through their
witty expertise in Newfound gray area
they're Unstoppable like them teaming up
to tank Howard's character was one of
the best arcs in television and had a
wildly insane payoff that had me dying
of laughter throughout however when Kim
and Jimmy aren't together the skill
shift for the better for Kim and for the
worse for Jimmy I love how they explore
this story-wise because when leaves
Jimmy she defaults to the most
stereotypical vanilla good life while
Jimmy goes off the deep end and risks
more and more for money this Duality is
such a juicy ju supposing relationship
that is oddly alluring and because of
this it makes for an incredibly engaging
character pairing that and the way they
left things between Kim and Jimmy was
perfect and really every ending for each
of the characters goes above and beyond
for great writing shifting my focus over
to Jimmy now what the show does for him
is pretty incredible they make one of
the most complex characters in The
Breaking Bad universe that has years of
backstory that weaves into every nanc of
his character's Journey whether that be
his complicated relationship with Chuck
Kim anchoring him down his criminal past
as slipping Jimmy his outlook on life in
which there are only wolves and sheep
and his main goal in life being the
pursuit of riches makes a delicious Hot
Pot combination of a character to me
he's just as interesting as Walter White
NOW Walter's overall Arc I think is the
magnum opus of character arcs in
television period but I think Jimmy as a
character Rivals Walter because he's
just as rich and I don't mean that
literally there's a ton of different
scenes and aspects in which you can
analyze and dive into for his character
but to say within season 6 I absolutely
love how the creators handled him for
the finale they essentially established
a character flaw through flashbacks in
which Jimmy states he has no regrets in
life I love how they also do this with
Mike and Walter because they really
question Jimmy about about the time
machine question like Jimmy only wanting
to go back in the past to either make
money or fix something as silly as an
injury but since we know Jimmy's pass
through the show we know he's lying to
himself if I had to do it all over
again I would maybe do some things
differently that you have regrets I have
regrets so the ending Arc for Jimmy is
that he wants to redeem himself and
rectify his biggest regret in life and
that's to make amends with his true love
Kim the way in which Vince Gilligan
explores this path for the finale I
think is utterly brilliant every scene
is actually a building block element to
get the Jimmy's Redemption despite it
not being obvious like the flashbacks
establishing the flaw the present where
Jimmy rolls his opposition by getting a
7-year plea deal which was genius
because he essentially hijacks Marie's
victimhood testimony and throws himself
into that pool by being a victim of
Walter as well then to him figuring out
that Kim confessed about Howard and is
able to bring her to the the court which
Sparks a revelation in which he can
Rectify his biggest regret to the
explosive climax of Jimmy admitting he
did everything for money to vindicate
himself in the eyes of Kim and also the
law and then the cherry on top with him
and Chuck in which we learned that Jimmy
always loved Chuck deep down to me this
is a perfect example of not a single
wasted scene or moment that builds to an
outstanding ending it's yet another
magnumopus ending within the Breaking
Bad Universe it's also pretty insane
because we both get the satisfaction of
Jimmy destroying his opposition in
courts by getting a seven-year plea deal
but he also does the right thing
character-wise by burning it all down to
redeem himself this overall tug-of warar
between Jimmy's criminal instincts and
his innocent AA of love with Kim is one
of the best complexities a character has
ever had it makes Jimmy a perfect
candidate for the main character of the
series because there's always a ton of
under the surface motivations desires
and goals that makes him one of the most
intriguing character characters in
television moving over to Mike since
he's also kind of the second main
character of the series due to him being
the protagonist of the drug war plotline
he's obviously amazing Mike has always
been a fan favorite because of his
lovable and honorable personality Better
Call Saul perfectly utilizes him and
even has some incredible arcs for him
even though it isn't in season 6 his
season 5 Arc with Warner zegler was
outstanding at first I thought this
whole development was rather
uninteresting about the whole backstory
of the creation of the underground lab
but the second they imbue this with a
heart-wrenching conflict of Warner
defecting it becomes magnetizing Mike
having to put him down is one of the
biggest tragedies in the show because
Warner is essentially the embodiment of
innocence and that's a line Mike never
wants to cross but he knows that he is a
lesser evil for killing wner it's one of
the most gutting scenes in the show and
is emotionally wrecking because Mike has
never been this torn apart emotionally
and the second Warner realized is his
fate your heart sinks he doesn't even
try to fight for his life and all he
wanted to do was ensure the safety of
his wife anytime this type of story
situation happens it's always gutting
like an ofm men and even The Green Mile
it's a free ticket to make you SOB and
the way it's executed here does so much
for Mike as a character Mike's season 6
time isn't as great since the main focus
is on Gus and lo but this season
actually has one of my favorite mic
scenes in which he meets Kim it's a
legendary comparing that sees the two
most hardened and witty characters have
a conversation and that alone is just so
entrancing I wish it could have been
longer but Mike's observation that Kim
was stronger than Jimmy was such a
gratifying moment I'd love to talk about
Mike for hours but let's move over to
nacho who I thought was a major surprise
nacho as a character is fundamentally
lovable because he's a victim who
desperately wants to escape to a better
life which he can do but since his
father is threatened with death he
chooses the selfless path of doing
everything in the interest of his safety
it creates an endearing quality for the
character in which we just want the best
for nacho he's a crucial perspective
within the world of Better Call Saul
because he's at his core and Underdog
we're always rooting for nacho to
succeed but given the nature of the show
in which anyone in the game receives
major consequences it turns Nacho's
overall story into a tragedy his ending
like everyone in the show is Flawless
and is imbued with an extremely raw and
intense performance along with his
entire Journey up until that point being
a crazily gripping ride throughout
Michael Mando is an excellent Gem of an
actor who goes all out in every scene
he's in I loved him all the way back in
Far Cry 3 as Vos and I hope he can get
more work in the future but regardless
his rendition of Nacho will probably
always be his best work and due to there
being so many other great characters and
actors in Better Call Saul I think he'll
sadly be overlooked especially given the
amount of competition at the emies
because he didn't even get nominated
which feels like a crime but to be fair
the competition is insane this year
although the White Lotus got a little
too many nominations so nacho to me will
always be a favorite because of how
surprisingly well acted written and
emotionally investing his entire story
was he's essentially the beating heart
that carries the entire drug war
plotline then within the sphere of the
drug world of Better Call Saul we have
an amazing addition to the Salam monka
family in Lo it's pretty crazy how the
salamas already had so many great
characters like Tuco Hector the twins
but yet Vince Gilligan somehow creates
the most intriguing member of the family
for Better Call Saul Lo is a powerful
figure with high intelligence Charisma
is cunning patient and my favorite
aspect about L is that he offsets his
verocity with an overwhelming presence
of kindness it creates an unnerving
presence for the character because he
gets under your skin with his fake
charade of warmth that he then uses to
catch characters offu with his deadly
seriousness
anytime he gives off this fake smile it
creates such a captivating scenario in
which you're trying to interpret what
the character is actually thinking it
adds a lot of depth to Lo in any given
moment because he's a Perpetual Enigma
which in turn highlights how great both
the writing and acting are for lo as a
character any confrontation he has with
an imposing character is absolutely
riveting because his unpredictability
makes him even more terrifying like
whenever he has conversations with Jimmy
and even Kim you never know the
direction it's going to go I'd love to
go into more depth about what makes Lo
such a great villain but that would turn
this already long video essay into
feature length he's hands down an
outstanding villain and it's really
impressive how he was able to break
through the already magnificent rostar
of iconic villains although I wouldn't
say he's the best because that title
definitely goes to Gus Fring I really
love How Better Call Saul adds a
significant amount of detail to Gus and
flushes him out even more seeing the
more personal side of Gus gives viewers
more content to the iconic villain that
we didn't get to see a lot of him
breaking bad we learned more details
about his character like his exacting
and OCD like personality that leads to
him being very observant the way in
which this comes through the most is how
he analyzes people with his cold and
unnerving stare I'll go into more about
this through the subtle and detailed
acting portion of the video because any
scene with Gus constantly oozes
subtextual value for storytelling and
that's all done through his Immaculate
performance he's a character that
requires an exacting attention to detail
because there are so many intricacies
that are constantly telling the audience
what he's thinking he's also arguably
the smartest character in The Breaking
Bad Universe probably just barely
underwater but this makes his entire
story thoroughly intriguing his overall
war with L was to merged an immense
tension and the way in which he C
overcomes it was a stroke of Brilliance
this also makes him a better character
because in Breaking Bad he primarily
loses to Walter on multiple fronts but
in Better Call Saul it brings back The
Mastermind aspect of of Gus Fring and
shows him in his full power besting an
opponents thus making him even more
deadly and terrifying which the way he
does defeat L was like a jigsaw level
Galaxy brain play in which he predicted
and accounted an exact outcome in which
he could be brought down to his lab and
every step of the way Gus made it very
convincing that Lo had won when in
reality Gus was always in control so
better Calla actually makes Gus an even
greater villain because we get to see
him overcome more conflict in his Prime
while also getting much more detailed
characteristics for the character just a
perfect way to handle Gus that obviously
isn't done in any kind of nostalgia bity
way he serves an integral function to
the story and isn't just here because he
was a fan favorite villain which a lot
of the times when fan favorite
characters return in popular franchises
it's really only done to make money
while here it actually elevates Gus now
going into what I would say is my least
favorite character we have Howard and
that's literally only because his compet
comptition is so insane that by virtue
he's my least favorite which isn't to
say he's a bad character because he's
still fantastic and I love him and if
anything the ending of Howard excels him
into a legendary status because I'd
honestly make the argument that Howard
may have the best ending and Better Call
Saul and that isn't just because his
ending is shocking and instead it's the
tragedy of it all this moment in the
story absolutely Flo you because you
never assume a character like Howard to
be entangled by the cartel but hey
actions have consequences and I think
this is also a perfect way to really
punish Kim and Jimmy initially I thought
there could be a possibility of Howard
killing himself in front of Jimmy and
Kim which would kind of mirror Chuck's
suicide ending but that was immediately
swatted away with the introduction of
the candle which I'll talk about later
in the hidden meeting section of the
video because this scene in general I
think is a complete masterclass in
filmmaking and I wanted to analyze it
further but going back to Howard's death
I think Lo abruptly killing him is
infinitely more TR tragic than a suicide
ending because this tragedy was forced
onto Howard right when he states that
he's going to overcome his shortcomings
he dies he was going to become a better
person and fight the toxicity of Jimmy
and Kim's powerful Duo but sadly that
optimistic future was ripped away from
him that and the implications of what
this does to Howard's character overall
is even more depressing because now all
that people remember him as is a Coke
addict who killed himself it yet again
means that Jimmy and Kim destroys the
legacy of a character although Kim
didn't really have that much involvement
with Chuck's downfall however Howard is
more tragic to me because it not only
tarnishes his reputation but he was also
an innocent character who was
unfortunately at the wrong place at the
wrong time so in general the creators
use Howard's death to really punctuate
the terrible ways in which Jim and Kimmy
affect people his character kind of
ascends and fulfills a higher story
purpose and that's something he never
would have expected to happen with a
character like Howard now before going
into the perfect prequel portion of the
video video I feel like it would be a
disservice to the show if I didn't
mention Chuck I'm trying to base this
video around the final season of the
show and why it's the best season of
television in 2023 while also being an
overall analysis But Chuck is inherently
an important part of Better Call Saul
his relationship and overall Feud with
Jimmy had a magnificent Arc of plenty of
ups and downs throughout the Four
Seasons and one of the best moments as
easily as Court monologue rancing about
Jimmy it's an excellent and euphoric
moment of payoff since Chuck has always
held this hate under the surface and
never express it out loud to anyone
unless if it was straight to Jimmy's
face but finally hearing this hate pour
out in public was like popping a massive
pimple and watching all the puss pour
out there's a lot to be analyzed between
Chuck and Jimmy that could also span
another big video essay but one aspect
that really intrigues me is the
subjective lens in which we view Chuck
as a character because in the show
objectively Chuck is a beloved character
who has done so much good in his career
but yet the writers only show us the bad
side of Chuck a spiteful Revenge field
brother that will never drop his
prejudice against Jimmy due to this
subjective lens it rallies us behind
Jimmy and shows us the true nature of
Chuck we're not showing the great side
of all of his good deeds and most of his
flashbacks generally show him in a bad
light and I also love how by orientation
to Jimmy Chuck is actually the
antagonist of the first four seasons
Chuck causes most of the conflict that
Jimmy overcomes and it just creates such
an interesting dynamic because on paper
Chuck should be a hero it establishes a
notion that despite how good you are you
can still have deep character flaws and
that makes truck feel so human Vince
Gilligan is an utter genius for creating
such an insanely Rich roster of
characters that I can honestly keep
gushing about but there are still four
other categories that Excel better call
S into being the best show of 2023
prequels in general can be very hard
because you can fall into the Trap of
creating an uninteresting story from the
audience already knowing the ending of
the main plot so there's a lot of
aspects you have to account for to make
a prequel just as great as the original
the first aspect is the choice to focus
a narrative on Jimmy if this was a
prequel of Walter White as an example
wouldn't be as investing because we
already know the set of events with
Elliott and the company Walter left
along with their not being much left to
learn about Walter as a character
through the course of Breaking Bad the
amount of backstory we get for sa
Goodman is pretty thin we understand
Saul Goodman but there's a lot of
background context that can be added to
his character so in general the show
operates to fundamentally expand and
fully flesh out Jimmy as a character
great prequels add to the characters at
hand and any mediocre prequel that
tackles pre-established characters are
never really that intriguing because
they lack exciting character
developments and often times communicate
redundant information that was already
communicated in the original that and
despite the show being called Better
Call Saul Mike also acts as a dual lead
in The Narrative because he has an
entire plot line dedicated to him now I
wouldn't say that Mike needed a lot more
development character-wise because his
motivations are relatively simple and
his personality is mostly the same
however the main interesting question
for Mike is how he ended up working with
Gus and Jimmy that's a major motivator
in capturing the audience's interest
because for a prequel you also need to
tell a story that will thoroughly
entertain the audience and this aspect
of the story is inherently a mystery in
Breaking Bad with the writers came up
with for these two leads was insanely
captivating while also greatly expanding
upon the world of bra bad because that's
another thing that every prequel needs
to do if you aren't exploring anything
new or mostly retreading old Waters then
you're doing a disservice to the world
you're telling your story in you have to
introduce new elements into the
narrative that the audience don't know
the resolution of like examples being
nacho Lo Howard Chuck and Kim these are
all characters that are new to us and
thus we don't know their endings the
only character out of this roster that
you'll know the ending of is L because
he's obviously not Breaking Bad and his
opponent Gus Fring survives their
conflict however the outcome of this
conflict isn't the alluring part of the
story and instead it's the way in which
Gus overcomes lo as a villain their
tug-of-war of conflict throughout
seasons 5 and six was incredible and
features some of the most witty and
engaging mind games this is a
complicated game of chess and despite us
knowing that Gus wins that game of chess
the way it's played is deeply riveting
and even though we can infer the ending
of Lo's character we don't know how
he'll impact other characters like Jimmy
and Kim our only assurance is that Jimmy
survives breaking bad but the fate of
Kim is in question and that in turn
mixes fear for her safety which this is
something that prequels need because
without this it can lead to shallow
stakes from us knowing the outcomes of
every part of the story stakes in
relative uncertainty as to where the
story is leading is what Hooks the
audience makes them want to keep
watching better Calla supplies this in
every season and essentially gets to a
point in seasons 5 and six where it even
matches the quality of Breaking Bad like
the resolutions of Nacho and Howard were
Sublime and these kind of moments being
in a prequel of all things is insanely
impressive given how hard it is to
create unpredictable plot threads and a
prequel story then one more aspect about
Better Call Saul is that it's also a
sequel to Breaking Bad so not only does
it add a lot of context to the story and
characters in the past it also gives
extended resolutions to ex existing
characters like one of the main ones
being Marie shider her testimony against
Jimmy was deeply emotional and she
utterly rails into him it gives her
character more of a satisfactory end
because she gets her justice against
Jimmy and more than just him going to
jail because she got to confront him
then for Jimmy the creators could have
left sa Goodman's end rather ambiguous
like Jesse's but it's an inherent
upgrade than him just being in hiding
for the rest of his life like sure you
can go in that direction for for the
story but it makes for a stronger
conclusion to continue it and create a
better payoff for Jimmy as a character
in which he gets a Redemption the fact
that better Calla is able to continue
the story and create another ending that
goes above Perfection is mindboggling to
me Vince Gilligan and his creative team
are just Geniuses so better call Sol as
a show is more than just a perfect
prequel but ascends the story
foundations of prequels and does even
more and before moving on I find it
really interesting how they use the
black and white style for the present
despite that generally being used to
portray the past to me it kind of
portrays the notion that Jimmy's life is
in General de saturated and lifeless and
is a husk of himself so not only is the
continued story outstanding but Vince
Gilligan is also making interesting
creative decisions to make the story
even deeper for the next two topics I'm
going to combine them since creative
visual storytelling and the hidden
meeting shown through it go hand inand I
feel like it's been a while since
cinematography of this caliber always
always makes me question and look into
the deeper meaning of what it's trying
to convey better call saw from the
blocking of actors framing lighting
scene Transitions and more are all
extremely deliberate and conveys some
kind of additive message that aids the
script to me this elevates the show
because it makes it significantly more
engaging and with engaging
cinematography it makes you an active
participant who is trying to pick up on
all the small details that these genius
creators leave behind it's in its R form
the definition of show don't tell in
which you want to engage the audience
mentally with not just words but every
frame even singular or quick shots can
convey so much information that it
essentially adds an additional Dimension
to the storytelling like let me play
this one scene transition and see if you
can spot the deeper meaning of what the
creators are trying to
communicate now initially this may not
seem like anything major but given the
future events of the show where Jimmy
and Kim split up I I believe this is a
small nugget of foreshadowing it can't
be a coincidence that we hard cut from a
shot of Jimmy and Kim kissing to someone
cutting a piece of wood in half which
also happens to be where the two
characters used to be in the frame now
for me personally I knew that Kim and
Jimmy would most likely split up by the
end of the show so this scene transition
immediately caught my attention now even
past the usage of creative
cinematography the creators regularly
use metaphors to convey certain messages
that makes the show even more
thought-provoking the biggest example is
the Creator's putting a lot of emphasis
on the ants devouring this ice cream
cone for me I interpret this as Jimmy
being the ice cream cone and the Ants
being the cartel Jimmy at this point in
the story is relatively innocent and has
not yet been fully corrupted or you can
even interpret this past the cartel and
apply it to Jimmy's entire later life of
only being surrounded by criminals his
innocence as a lawyer and someone who
wants to do some amount of good has
completely melted away the moment that
cements this metaphor is Jimmy's
reaction into the ice cream cone and not
seeing his overall dissatisfaction he
knows that there is no going back and
his future is going to be very Grim
another great example is the opening of
episode 3 of season 6 where we have this
long tracking shot that reveals a
beautiful blue flower in the desert
alongside a piece of glass at first this
doesn't mean anything to the viewer
until we see the ending and find out
that this piece of glass is what nacho
used to escape with so in a heartfelt
way the creators are signifying that
this gorgeous blue flower represents
nacho he was the innocent flower amidst
the desolate and miserable Wasteland of
the drug world it's a really intelligent
moment that rewards the viewer for
paying attention to the details of the
show and the second the episode ended
with that final shot I was kind of blown
away and you can also interpret the
storm in the beginning as Nacho's
upcoming dark fate now even going past
metaphors the creators also use certain
objects and scenes and abue them with a
certain importance a subtle example that
I love is the candle announcing the
arrival of Howard and lo now the reason
why I'm bringing this up is because it's
unnatural to establish an element like
this when Howard already announces
himself via
knocking so it's a redundant piece of
information that instead acts to
establish an alternate way of announcing
the entrance of a character so when it
inevitably comes back up again with Lo's
sudden entrance you as a viewer
immediately know what's happening also
this is a part that I love but if you're
really paying attention to this
unconventional shot it adds a layer of
mystery and overall dread to the scene
because now you're asking yourself why
did the creator suddenly use this candle
and will it come back up again meaning
that there could be an additional
surprise character that shows up towards
the end of the scene along with the
framing of Howard's entrance being
somewhat mysterious in which he isn't
revealed until he's in the apartment and
all we have is Jimmy's reaction which is
partially similar to The Dread likee
feeling of Lo entering the apartment
where he emerges from the Shadows this
in contrast to the first time L shows up
to the apartment is different because
initially it was meant as a sudden
surprise while here the creators build
this uneasy atmosphere with Howard's
meltdown and climax it with Lo killing
him that and there's so much more to
analyze just with this single scene like
with the lighting and overall color it's
shot in such a horror-like way of using
atmospheric lighting to establish this
anxious tone along with the harsh
oranges pushing Howard's manic
realization even further and guess what
there's even more to be analyzed with
this scene through the evolution of The
Blocking lighting and editing the scene
with Howard starts in which he walks
into the kitchen that is lit much
brighter and doesn't communicate this
uneasy tone yet then as the scene
progresses he positions himself in front
of this Dark Void in which the living
room is behind him through this absence
of light it gives us less security
because of that innate feeling of being
scared of the dark like hell that's how
they brilliantly introduce Lo into the
scene he starts out as the shadow
creeping into the frame behind Howard
which significantly adds to the horror
then for the editing the scene first
starts with using wide shots and over
the course of it the shots get Tighter
and Tighter it progresses this feeling
of claustrophobia and essentially ends
with a close-up on Howard and the second
we finally get to the shot we
immediately know that something is off
because through basic escalation we know
that this closest shot is essentially
the climax and it's framed in such a way
to keep the background behind him
visible like sorry if I'm over an I
izing this one scene but I think this
illustrates the point in which there's
an insane amount of subtext and under
the surface subtle storytelling that is
happening in almost every scene I'm
mainly highlighting Howard's death scene
because I think it's a perfect
combination of everything whether that
be through cinematography editing
blocking props coloring and more it's
invigorating as a viewer to really sink
your teeth into these scenes because
there's so much depth to them every
aspect of film making is operating at
such a high quality that it makes the
show a true feast like Vince Gilligan
isn't just a writing genius but a
filmmaking genius through and through
one of the most brilliant scenes of a
show I watched and it isn't just great
because it was shocking but because of
how genius the creators went about in
telling it another scene that really
caught my attention that I want to point
out before moving on was the way in
which they edited Jimmy and Kim going
about their lives while Mike cleaned up
their apartment now I'm a sucker for
amazing scene transitions because they
can really boost the cleverness of your
film or show and the vast majority of
the time filmmakers don't do anything
special with them however here
contrasting Mike Jimmy and Kim's day
with match cuts and resolves was utterly
brilliant through them cutting between
the coffee pouring into a cup to
squeezing out blood into a bucket Mike
washing blood off the floor to Jimmy
soaking up the red sauce of his lunch
with bread Kim providing evidence of a
dead victim to Mike looking at a picture
where Howard's body used to be every
transition in the scene is infused with
so much creativity that it makes it
incredibly thought-provoking this
attention to detail and planning out
these scene transitions elevates the art
in my opinion it shows how much care the
creators are putting into this scene
because this goes past just editing the
creators have to plan out these shots
and think about the significance of
their meaning and how it adds more to
the story to me it establishes a genius
parallel between these three characters
of just opposing their ordinary lives to
the horror of what's going on in their
home it's brilliant and so are so many
other scenes and shots within this
Artful show for the last great aspect of
better Calla I want to highlight how
great the subtle acting is throughout
the show and how the creators use
minimalist dialogue to let the actors
really shine and carry the narrative
through their performances I said I was
going to return to Gus frering in this
section and that's because I think he's
the best example of the subtle form of
acting his dead pan and blunt like
serious delivery creates a shroud of
mystery as what his intentions and
motivations are because of this we have
to really pay attention to the subtle
intricacies of J Carlo's performance to
pick up on the smallest of details that
allude to different aspects of the story
like one of my favorite examples being
his talk with Hector salamona after the
death of Lo Hector as well especially
with his added context through Better
Call Saul really adds a deeper layer to
his acting every moment you can see
Hector's emotion pour through his
performance despite not being able to
deliver any lines of dialogue like his
reaction to hearing Lo's voice and
transforming his expression from being
depressed to excited was great but going
back to his scene with Gus I love the
subtle mind games on display here Gus
picks up on the small detail of Hector
being partially proud and arrogant when
normally he hates Gus this signals to
Gus that something is wrong which means
that Lo is most likely alive from here
Gus bases his entire plan around Lo
being alive just from this one tiny
little interaction it's a genius moment
for Gus as a character that makes him
come across as being incredibly
observant and intelligent I also love
the scene after L's death and which he
gets questioned by donadio the scene is
infused with palm sweating tension and
as an audience we eagerly watch Jan
Carlo's performance for any minor tells
subtle moments include Gus trying to
hide his pain while being pat down by
the security guard Gus's long pondering
introduction slightly portraying a
nervous tone when he says he has no
response there's a minor hesitant blink
because he's making a ballsy play Then
when asked as to if that's truly his
response to the allegation he reaffirms
his stance with a more confident
delivery as the scene progresses and
donadio makes the case for Gus his s
hardens it becomes even more confident
and then this might also be a hidden
meaning aspect or me overanalyzing but
when Gus looks over at Hector there's a
reflection of fire in Gus's glasses
which could portray his fiery hatred
towards Hector or it could just be a
coincidence which again there's a lot to
be analyzed in so many scenes in Better
Call Saul but going back to the subtle
acting point this scene is Thoroughly
engaging because we have to pay strict
attention to his performance there's so
many subtleties and insinuations being
made that it makes the story of the
scene so complex and intriguing I know
scenes with reams of dialogue and
monologues are clear standouts but these
types of smaller moments in which the
dialogue Falls away and performances
take the Forefront of our attention are
equally as brilliant that and it's not
just Gus and there's a plethora of
moments between every character in which
the writers use minimalist dialogue to
allow the acting of these great actors
to carry the storytelling like more
examples are Nacho's final scene with L
where nacho has to internalize the
oncoming Doom of everyone's death in the
compound almost any scene in the present
with Jimmy Kim's boiling anger towards
Jimmy when he defects and goes against
her wishes during the Mesa Verde problem
Lo coldly considering Jimmy's proposal
to send Kim to kill Gus which
drastically increased the tension and
almost every mic scene since his usage
of dialogue is meticulous and efficient
the acting in better kalol is
outstanding and it's unfortunate that
success ession will most likely win
every category it's nominated in our
only true hope is that Ria Sehorn wins
for best supporting actress because to
me she is the best in that category I
know I'm titling this video as being the
best show of 2023 and that should in
turn invite a compare and contrast
between succession and better call saw
but both of these shows are easily 10
out of 10 along with them being pretty
different types of shows so it's
obviously off of your personal
preference and I just wanted to make a
case for why better call SA is the best
show because I feel like it deserves
more praise it's one of the most
brilliant shows I've ever seen and thank
you so much for watching this entire
lengthy video essay I didn't intend on
it going this long but it would have
felt like a disservice to the show
making it any shorter let me know in the
comments what you think about Better
Call Saul and my socials are linked in
the
description and again thank you so much
to my top patreon Logan farmer I can't
express how thankful I am for you
hitting the highest tier